قبل لحظات ، كان الأطفال
يلعبون في ساحة المدرسة ، كانت
الساعة حوالي الرابعة مساءً.  عندما بدأ الإضراب لكنهم
لم يكونوا هناك لأن الفصول خرجت للتو ،
ولكن لأن تلك المدرسة
مثل العديد من المدارس الأخرى قد تم تحويلها إلى
ملجأ ، يسير الرجل بالقرب من
الزاوية ويتحدث إلى امرأة تقول
إنها مصابة بشظية في قدمها  لم
ينجُ جميعهم من تلك الضربة أو الضربة التسعة الأخرى
التي ضربت المدارس في محافظة إدلب في
نفس اليوم ، حيث كان العديد ممن كانوا يأويون
الفارين من العنف في أماكن أخرى
هبة ، ناشطة إعلامية تمشي في
المدرسة وتحولت الفصول الدراسية إلى
أماكن للمعيشة نعتقد أننا
بأمان ،  تأتي الطائرات الحربية وتأخذ
كل شيء منا ، وتقول إن روسيا
رفضت الدعوات لوقف إطلاق النار قائلة
إن ذلك سيكون استسلامًا
للإرهابيين ، ومع ذلك فإن
قصف النظامين الروسي والسوري
لإدلب لم يقتصر على الخطوط الأمامية
أو الجماعات المسلحة ، بل
استهدف بشكل منهجي.  السكان المدنيون
يجبرون المزيد من الناس على الفرار
ويكثفون الآن الهجمات على مدينة عابرة
نفسها
على حافة منطقة صغيرة  مجموعة من الخيام
ليست بعيدة عن الحدود المغلقة للديوك الرومية ،
انتقلت عائلة ممتدة واحدة تحت الأرض إلى
كهف من صنع الإنسان تم حفره في الأصل
لإيواء الأبقار والماعز ، ولم يكن لديهم
ما يكفي من المال لشراء خيمة ، وهناك
حوالي 45 منهم يعيشون هنا مثل هذا
بعد  قضاء أيام في تجريف
البراز والقذارة دون تلوث بشيء ينذر بالسوء
عندما ينام الأطفال ، نتناوب النساء
على النظر إليهم للتأكد من عدم
وجود ثعابين أو عقارب.
الأطفال مرضى
وهم بالكاد قادرون على الحصول على الدواء
، لا توجد حرارة داخل الكهف ، يتم
طهي الطعام في الهواء الطلق حيث يقوم الأطفال بتدفئة
أنفسهم طوال
أيامهم المنزلية دون خوف ، وهو مفهوم
يبدو غريبًا جدًا حلم بعيد المنال
للملايين المحاصرين في إدلب  في حرب
منذ البداية لم يكن لها قواعد ولا
خطوط جبهات حقيقية وحيث الأمان ليس
أكثر من مجرد وهم ممزق